We are shaped by group level of
selection processes so that we can be
like bees in a hive.
Um,
we are not just primates.
We evolved to fight it out with other
primates.
Uh,
we are part way through a major
transition evolutionary history that
allows us to be temporarily like bees in
a hive.
We see this after a attacks.
We saw it after nine 11.
We can come together our propensity to
find meaning,
even though it may have evolved from
simpler cognitive mechanisms as Richard
Dawkins and others maintain.
Um,
I believe that our ability to find
connections to see connections in the
stars.
If we look up at the sky,
we see stories about people wandering
around and going on missions.
Um,
I believe that our ability to find
connections and meaning helps us merge
together into groups,
uh,
that can function as one.
Um,
so this is part of the psychology that
allows us to create these emergent super
organisms,
at least temporarily.
Um,
anyone who's ever been in part of being
in a chorus or band or played a team
sport or been initiated into a
fraternity,
knows the joy is the ecstasy of losing
yourself in part of a larger group.
I think this is the next frontier for
psychology and for the social sciences
is understanding that we are not radical
individuals.
We are actually in part bees in a hive,
but we don't live that way.
And that's the reason for as much,
right?
We are deeply and profoundly
confirmation secrets not truth seekers.
The most important rule in psychology is
that thinking is for doing.
Now there are some people whose task it
is to find the truth.
So you might think they would use
thinking to find the truth.
And there are some philosophers I think
who are very open minded.
There are some,
uh,
but for the most part,
philosophers are human beings too.
Uh,
and they use reasoning to reach the
conclusion that they find a minute,
uh,
amenable or conducive.
Um,
um,
you have to look back at the divisions
of the mind and realize that our
language ability,
our ability to think in words,
did not come about so that we could
figure things out.
Language came about to communicate and
especially to influence.
We use reasoning to influence others,
to manage our reputation to,
to,
to work out well,
what will people think of me if I do
this?
And is that person trying to cheat me?
We use reasoning,
uh,
in a machiavellian way.
Quite often.
Um,
we are capable of using it to find the
truth when we don't care about the
truth.
And this is why the natural sciences do
such a good job.
They can really reason their way to the
conclusion offered by the data and the
social sciences.
We have a big problem.
Almost all of us are liberal,
not in economics,
but in psychology,
sociology,
anthropology,
almost all of us are liberal.
So we reasoned our way to conclusions we
want to reach,
which are liberal conclusions.
Um,
and this makes it very hard for us to
understand society,
religion,
politics,
knowledge.
Okay.
The basic personality trait is that
predicts ideology best is openness to
experience.
This is just a fact about the
distribution of personality types.
Just as some people are extroverted,
some introverted,
it's always going to be the case as part
of a genetic shuffle.
But some people just like novelty
variety and diversity,
other people like what's familiar.
Um,
I'm really glad it's this way.
Uh,
we need in any community we need people
of both types.
What happens now that we have so much
geographic mobility is the people who
are high in openness to experience can't
stand to live in small towns.
They all moved to New York and San
Francisco and Boston create communities
that are very high in openness to
experience in which there is no moral
diversity,
uh,
whereas other people who are born low
and more on openness to experience and
move out.
Um,
so we now get geographic and social
clustering where we only have to deal
with people who are like us.
Um,
the food is really,
really good where we liberals live
because we like ethnic foods.
We like variety in the more conservative
parts of the country.
It seems like all the restaurants are
applebee's because they don't like
bright in diversity,
uh,
that much.
So this basic personality trait,
um,
drives so much else that happens and
leads us to cluster into groups.
It used to be that at least if you were
born in one place,
you were likely to stay,
that most people stayed and you
associated with people who were near
you.
But we're often different from you.
Not Anymore.
Now we've got lots of,
of racial and ethnic diversity.
That's great.
But we've been able to purchase it at
the cost of almost no model diversity.
The data suggests that Americans are
among the happiest people in the world.
Um,
uh,
it's the scandinavians also do extremely
well on that.
Um,
the most important thing to realize for
those who doubt that those who doubt
that Americans are happy is to realize
that happiness is really local.
Um,
our society is screwed up in a lot of
ways.
Uh,
we have a lot of poverty.
We have a lot of injustice.
We have a broken political system,
um,
and some of that matters for happiness.
But for the most part,
our happiness comes from our local
environment,
from our relationships,
from having control over our lives.
Um,
I do think the data suggests that,
uh,
freedom is good for people.
Uh,
up to a point.
Um,
mobility and diversity are not so good
for people.
Uh,
they do,
uh,
they do make us trust our neighbors
less.
Uh,
so anything that fosters strong
relationships and stable,
a stable,
a healthy,
cohesive communities is generally good
for us.
Um,
but anything that fosters anime and
distrust and chaos is bad for us.
I think America could do a lot better.
I think we could be even happier than we
are if we could fix some of our social
problems.
Um,
but I do think that despite all of our
problems,
uh,
Americans seem to be doing pretty well
on a happiness scale.
Okay.
Myth of pure evil is a term
coined by the psychologist Roy
Baumeister.
Um,
which talks about a kind of a narrative
that we all have in our minds.
Um,
it's parodied most perfectly in the
Austin Powers movies in which there is a
Dr Evil who does evil because he loves
to do evil.
There's no other motive.
He just likes to do evil.
Um,
uh,
we on the other hand are perfectly good.
We fight evil.
So it takes extent that you have bumper
stickers on your car.
Things like,
if you don't like abortion,
don't have one.
Um,
um,
you think that you are on the good side
and those ignorant fools and the other
side are evil,
uh,
driven by ignorance or greed.
Um,
we liberals tend to think about racism
in this way,
especially.
We think that racism is pure evil and
racism happens for no reason.
It just falls out of the sky.
Um,
and it's a disease and a virus.
We must all unite to fight this pure
evil.
This is what I mean when I say morality
is a team sport and Airside is united by
fighting the pure evil of racism.
Um,
the reality is always more complicated
as baumeister shows,
even in domestic violence,
one of the most obvious cases of
apparent case of pure evil,
whether you're looking at domestic
violence,
racial assaults,
whatever it is,
murder especially,
there's usually,
uh,
an escalation.
There's usually some fault on both
sides.
It hurts me to say that I know that
people watching this are going to be
offended because I've just said
something sack religious for our,
our social justice side.
Um,
but the reality is always more
complicated.
Um,
you cannot understand the atrocities in
the world by thinking they are caused by
evil.
In fact,
almost all the trustees are caused by
people pursuing the good,
who believe at the ends.
Justify the means.
There is no pure evil.
It's actually moral motives,
a cloaked in a cloak of self
righteousness.